republican national committee chairwoman
ronna mcdaniel
great to see you today first of all
let's start with where
or how americans will immediately feel a
quadrupling
of the cap on refugees to the united
states
well these border states and the border
personnel are going to be inundated even
more
because what joe biden keeps doing is
putting a magnet out
to draw people to this country illegally
putting them in harm's way
putting them in the hands of cartels who
they have to pay to make this dangerous
track
and it's impacting children at a
significant rate many who are dying as
they make this journey
so instead of saying let's tackle the
immigration problem let's have
immigration reform
he keeps throwing quick fixes out there
that
that appease the democrat progressive
left
without actually solving a root problem
and boy i feel so bad for our border
patrol agents who are so overwhelmed
right now and they have a president and
a white house who doesn't care about
them
and the task they're undertaking well
and it's so interesting to hear you talk
directly about the families the refugees
particularly about the children because
we know
um the pressure that is happening at the
border
right now in terms of protecting
children and what a huge job it is as
you point out
for the border patrol and albanian
refugee
peter lamage says biden's decision to
raise the refugee cap
is not about helping people though watch
this
why is he increasing the number of
refugees now what is the intent
the intent of the democrat party is to
create a permanent
underclass in united states so it can be
dependent on the government and create a
voting bloc
for the future of the democratic party
so we should understand the
intent is not to bring these people to
get them
out of misery and out of suffering
an interesting first-person perspective
your reaction to it
i think he's doing tremendous harm to
these families who are coming here
for with hope and want to come to the
united states of america
but are being put in the hands of
cartels and i talked to governor abbott
last week he said there is not a single
person coming across our border
who is not being dealt with with the
cartels they have to pay the cartels to
cross
in the united states of america and many
many children are dying along the way
and suffering horrific abuses as they
come to this country
and joe biden and kamala harris not only
will they not go to the border they
haven't even spoken to the governors who
are dealing with this
firsthand so he's putting a policy in
place he keeps aoc happy and
durbin and the progressive left but it
is a catastrophe
for everybody who's dealing with it in
real time in our southern states
how is it that the progressives on the
hill have more pressure and and can get
more effective action from this
president than millions of americans
you know he ran as a moderate harris we
know this he ran as i'm going to unite
people we saw his inaugural speech
he has been nothing but i tweeted a
couple days ago he has spoken more to
chi
uh and putin than he has to mccarthy and
mcconnell he has no interest working
across the aisle but i think it's really
telling that they haven't gone to the
border
and talk to the agents and talk to the
families and talk to the people
who are really dealing with this crisis
firsthand
and that shows that he's not really
interested in solving the problem
he's interested in giving to his
progressive friends
and making sure they get their win
chairwoman mcdaniel we heard that one
albanian refugee
talk about well biden's not focused
on helping the children here's some
children that maybe can get the
president's attention
attention different subject some fifth
graders in virginia
went way off script apparently they were
asked
to simply tell president biden and the
first lady what remote
learning has really been like watch
when we were really tired then we could
take
[Music]
[Music]
you didn't no it was terrible i liked it
one student said it was terrible we have
children we we know firsthand
chairwoman what the journey has been
like uh one third of students just to
remind everybody
still in the united states right now are
not getting full-time in-person learning
so
a cup of truth from the kids i know i
think it's the first time
the biden that president biden took
unscripted
questions or talking points from from
children i also think
it's interesting that the cdc is taking
their guidance from teachers unions
maybe they should talk to the children
because this is what it's about
kids who are lacking in education who
aren't getting that in-person
instruction
who are are getting a gap in what they
need
to get ahead i think tim scott put it so
well in his speech he said kids being
locked out of the classroom today are
being
our future adults being locked out of of
their potential
and that is so true and i have a son
who's in virtual i'd be happy for him to
pick up the phone
and talk to president biden about how
awful it is for him
um it is really really catastrophic for
these kids i deal with it firsthand
and it's sad that this administration is
putting the unions
above the children and that's the
problem across this country right now
democrats
are putting the unions above the science
and the children because we know it's
safe for them to go back in the
classroom right now
chairwoman ron mcdaniel i do want to get
to this before i
let you go democrats are locked out of a
texas runoff election
that race will now see two republicans
susan wright
jay kelsey facing off for a
congressional seat in north texas
even a washington post op-ed is calling
it a bad
omen for team blue here's the quote
if this result is a harbinger of the
midterms democrats are in for a
bloodbath
as the suburbs snap back into
republicans
lockstep you know what's interesting
about this you and i have talked so many
times about how
productive and successful the rnc has
been at those door knocks
imagine post you know a time when many
people are fully vaccinated post that
time where people might not open their
doors
if you get back out there right now is
that op-ed right
oh we were out there i mean we were
knocking doors we contacted 4 000 voters
to get them out we knew we had to target
likely republicans in that district
and you know what the democrats did it
too they were fighting for this seat so
don't let them pretend that they were
walking away this was their best chance
to flip a house seat
and they came up empty and they ran 11
points behind
joe biden in 2020. this is
huge for republicans that we walked away
with two republicans in the runoff
and we're going to pick up another house
seat which shrinks nancy pelosi's margin
heading into 2020 20
2022 where we're five seats away from
taking back the majority
real quickly every president just about
pretty much loses in that first midterm
right because
it's kind of a resetting point what
people think they want they kind of like
a little split government
uh bloodbath is some strong language for
you know the washington post what's your
quick take on on just how bad it could
be
well i never want to get comfortable i
want everybody to to
work hard but we we can take back the
house it is
five seats away uh usually it's 26 seats
in a midterm
but republicans have to show up we have
to be united
let's remember what joe biden's doing to
this country and not focus
on our inner disputes we've got to work
together if we're going to win and take
back the house
in 2022. ronald mcdaniel chairwoman of
the rnc great to see you today thank you